bien aux excuses d'écouté peut-être
avez-vous tricher en cours hier
peut-être êtes-vous salariés et avez
vous trichez notre adolescence à au
brevet et au bac au mato aujourd'hui les
amis on va retourner à cette époque
parce qu'on va devoir tricher sans se
faire griller c'est l'heure de passer un
examen on a trouvé les réponses on doit
partager les réponses parce qu'on est
des gens biens est à moi je triche et je
veux pas là pour ça fuck you off je vous
laisse tout ça il faut pas se faire
choper un terreau propice aux débats de
baseball calais cette école ok ce parti
ok il faut qu'ils aient des bonnes
réponses pour pouvoir lancer les
distractions du coup je perds quoi en
tendant à lui hommes il avait sa main et
là je cherche du coup je copie je copie
mais je suis devant lui va moins bien
c'est bon aux bâtards
pas de banat il a dit j'étais chez
tempus prix de bananes ok ça marche
alors on redouble notera des crèmes
[ __ ] quand je suis tout devant mais
quand tu étais cher je suis tout
impossible non c'est lui voilà lui tient
et la blache potiche est tranquille là
la loi fille sera dans un mauvais sens
c'est bon vas-y je passe la halle la
réponse à lui il est de dos il voit pas
au classement du top ces lois qui
parlait et madame est vraie réponse à
lui mais je suis baiser la faut que
j'attende profile de loterie de la
classe mais il ya jamais de tri de
l'acacia qu'un seul mec habib a marqué
les failles sur sa copie ça peut faire
mieux surveiller ok je peux chanter je
peux chanter c'est bon se passe avec lui
il est plus là lui c'est celui qui est
chargé de chercher les réponses du coup
je suis mort du coup j'ai qu'une réponse
que je vais donner en boucle chez auto
près de lui vite vite vite elle arrive
elle arrive elle arrive c'est bon elle a
fait demi tour il va appeler le prof lui
va parler à lui pendant ce temps là
non juste medicare
non c'est bon trois sur cinq élèves ont
réussi à passer l'examen c'est pas mal
mais on s'en bat les couilles des autres
voies juste le passé 12 ans mais c'est
vrai non mais arrêtez arrêtez avec ces
deux minutes avec vos manoeuvres ou
pseudo valeurs là un chacun à sa gueule
ça les examens ok le but c'est qu'ils
passent tous mais comme en thuringe
avertissent le gros baisse qui s'est mis
au fond de la classe il est co fallait
c'était pas loin donc si vous voulez
qu'on l'aide ok alors vas-y toi tu vas
là tu irais je vais chercher pas de
réponse mais qu'on attend dans ok jadona
lui ok lui la donne à lui fait vite et
félice éviter ok toi tu va rappeler de
son entourage à mettons en exergue et
désolé mon gars mais toi tu vas passer à
lui il va attirer la prof et lui il va
envoyer le hb peut pas aller trop loin
mais comment je fais si j'envoie un
avion de papier oh merde on n'a
pas de bananes a du coup comment je fais
pour bhp pu l'envoyer il ya plus mais qu
on voit des avions quand je fais les
trois là ils ont eu la réponse je peux
pas sauter à lui de loin au ps je lui
crie je veux créer des photos que je me
tais tu n'as jamais ça ok retravaille
cette fois on passe tom cruise mon pote
[Musique]
oui oui
bon ça c'est l'absence de tom cruise sa
mort mais voilà ils sont tous à venir la
grosse brute qui s'est mis au fond de la
classe à temps mais en vrai en bref
voici le schéma de clasquin vrai prof
aurait fait aux mondiaux tamedia trop
dure la roque et de ses deux petits
génies lui il a la réponse il va la
passer ok la passe à lui ok lui la
réponse la baston au hasard vite vite
vite vite
ses limites flip c'est quoi ça emmerde
c'est pour attirer mais complètement
compter disqualifiés quand tu fais sa
patrie pourquoi tu t'es sacrifiés c'est
pas moyen distinctes tout ça c'est un
moyen d d'échec scolaire
[Musique]
auquel cherche vite cherche vite non
attends là m'a fait arriver au courant
pour né des balayages calme-toi latvala
trois élèves sur 11 ok ok je vais leur
attirer le temps que lui le dise à lui
ok c'est bon c'est bon à rien mais daria
bus pas avec moi je lui demande un stylo
on la connaît bien celle là bas les
dégager il a bien dégagée elle et passe
le annick avec sa crête dégueulasse
dilue d'un fou liste de chant et coupe
de cheveux justement qu'ils appellent la
prof toit s'est passé à lui et là ils
ont tous on est bon sauf le coup qui
s'est fait griller 10 sur 11
hier niveau suivant ils vont être
combien attendez sont des classes de 30
la au hockey ce parti en charge de la
recherche directe hayatou prof à temps
mais le média le mail qu'il a des
lunettes de splinter cell calme-toi toi
appel
c'est bon j'ai fait tous mes temps mais
c'est complètement qu'on aille se
sacrifie when the queen qui fait ça qui
fait un film tu es mieux pour protéger
son pack qui rentre à donner les
réponses personne met ko qu'il faut que
j'envoie un avion au [ __ ] mais que ça
va être chaud faut que j'envoie dans la
rangée là-bas faudrait que lui fasse un
truc avec pk ch ok je le tente
[Musique]
tel un missile
au bien commun dégagé juste même puisque
les faits il y a une bonne tête mais ça
passe ou pas 7 sur 13 au [ __ ] mais
c'est dur là là deux profs mais faut
arrêter les conneries là ok cette fois
on se concentre sur ce qui est venu en
chercher il me l'a trouvé excusez moi
bin moi s'étonnait réponse by mess de
mer et mons par abidal huila us par as
par ali dégage c'est pas grave il faut
qu'je des sacrifices non non on en fait
vite savez toilettes flip j'ai pété un
câble c'est bon on a par contre eu droit
à l'erreur mais sa taille un prof qui
est parti mais qu ils à être cas c'est
ma chance et malchance ils étaient
combien combien c'est bon là c'est bon
là avec le prof six verges contre une
table l'igas
[ __ ] on est en train de faire un
cartel de tricheurs mon pote au
machisme c'est manuel r d lui la vie on
va faire un petit avion ont envoyée à
ceux du milieu ici à l'efi le fiston
avions plus vite mon gars tu n'as pas
pris option origami pour rien brevets
bon c'est bon capital q vous êtes prof
qui peut lever la main la toile et wlan
la mecque personne n'est mort tout le
monde a la réponse viau et lui va dire à
lui c'est fini non le but de maxime la
perfection un pavé mec si j'ai fait un
père fait j'ai bien professeurs moi
je parviens à qui dégage alain qui
dégage tranquille en plus comme par
hasard c'est le mec assis au fond c'est
tout seul bien dégagé 16 on a des très
bons espoirs de côté toi tu es la
recherche tokai de la main
pierre début de d'espionnage du monde en
plus il lève la main lui léguer à lui
maintenant ils avaient la banane au
times un ça va [ __ ] mais c'est super
dur fait suite fait prendre une fois
sali que la chaîne des réponses en fait
il faudrait donner de réponse avec un
avion comme ça ils donnent à penser
l'autre angers et les deux d'orange et
ont des réponses moi c'est plutôt
d'avoir le bac de résoudre cette énigme
n'importe quoi le cai là il est comme ça
la douce retour effet au plus tard lui
je vais ça va tâcher pas pourquoi et
comme par hasard ça va te celui qui
trouvera les réponses mais ça va chier
ça va chier on va faire de la [ __ ] de
corde à sauter avec se calme et on va y
arriver comme les boxeurs en sort très
bon ok je vais expliquer la strata va
super bien marché regardez en gros je
vai les attirer ici lui lève la main et
lui on sait pas pourquoi ils vénèrent m6
j'ai raté en année et il soulève sa
table là je vais passer les réponses
prévoyez pendant qu'un 1 qui passe une
réponse avec le ch peut plus la passe et
c'est fini ça sachant que j'ai une
minute du coup peut pas et puis tu que
ça voyez ce que c'est impossible depuis
que ça avec une âme est réel et mais qui
se mettent à deux spots de la classe que
voulez vous que je fasse quand c'est
comme ça voilà regardez là j'ai pas pu
faire plus vite je fais des codes parce
que c'était un père dont je ne peux pas
faire mieux que ça et 6 en 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 20 22 recalés parfait non mais je peux
pas faire au dessus de
15-13 j'ai fait
si j'ai des cliques petit je suis
toujours tranquille sur une rangée mais
jamais sur deux en même temps et je peux
pas aller plus vite la dame et je suis
allée hyper vite je peux pas aller plus
vite que ça
[Musique]
c'est le dernier [ __ ] des cga la route
a droit qu'à un essai dans la vraie vie
[Musique]
le lendemain squeeze se rendit aux
résultats du bac avec ses copains il
découvrait alors qu'ils étaient refusés
à ce dernier pour cause de triche il dut
alors annoncé la nouvelle à ses parents
et se retrouva avec le cul plus rouge
que rodman et rata année après année
l'examen jusqu'à avoir six en décalage
avec les gens de sa classe fin
[Musique]
et là je suis enfin de cette démo sur la
school c'était très très bien jusqu'au
dernier le bel n'hésitez pas aimé la
vidéo ça vous appuyez franchement c'est
dur [ __ ] je pense pas que ce soit
aussi dur le dernier niveau nous a mis
ko un plat sans diplôme vous pouvez
laisser si vous voulez c'est gratuit il
ya de la déception est plus forte dans
une prochaine vidéo portez vous bien
jack
[Musique]